so one of the projects that I'm
currently working on is basically
building large-scale simulation models
of economic systems and financial
markets in particular and banks are
really important part of a modern
economic system and a very important
part of the financial system and I would
like my simulation models to be
reasonably well calibrated to the real
world and so I'm focusing on trying to
kind of establish the facts on the
ground about what did what do what does
the banking sector look like in the US
how can we characterize kind of
important stylized facts about the
banking system that we can then hope to
bring into our simulation models right
so I have a hypothesis my hypothesis is
that the bank size distribution in the
United States is probably going to be
well approximated at least and the upper
tail by a power law more specifically
I'm going to focus on something called
zips law which if you're not familiar
with is basically just a power law
distribution where the scaling exponent
takes a particular value to in this case
zips law comes up a lot I think it was
originally specified for the frequency
of words in text documents but it has
come up again in the distribution of
City sizes and we're going to look at it
in the context of bank and the context
of banks there's been a lot of research
that has looked at the distribution of
firm sizes and you could kind of go on
and on and on and on and power laws and
zips law come up again and again it
again so it seems like a pretty a pretty
reasonable null hypothesis there's the
canonical citation to zipps law for firm
sizes so where is the data that I'm
going to use for this study come from
well the in the United States all
commercial banks are regulated by the
federal deposit insurance corporation
and and so they collect quite a lot of
data a very detailed balance sheet data
every quarter from every bank that they
regulate in the US and so the banks have
to report everything about kind of the
distribution of their assets the
distribution of the reliabilities the
kinds of capital that they hold on
books that constitute their equity base
very very detailed fine-grained data and
it's publicly available kind of so the
FDIC has this very bureaucratic web
access form that you can use to access
the data and you go to the website and
you point click drop down menu select
subselect blah blah blah this goes on
and on and on and on forever and then if
you go if you use that kind of entry
point to get your data of course you get
a small Excel spreadsheet with is a
small snippet of their data and they
don't have a nice data API like the
bureau of economic analysis in the US
where you can just kind of plug in and
download JSON data or XML data in bulk
yet so you kind of have to hack together
a little Python script which I did and
put on github for anybody who else you
might be interested in grabbing this
data and format it into a nice pandas
panel object and the panel data is is
really nice for this setup because you
get there's both the cross sectional
component in terms of the individual
banks that are in the data set over time
but then also a time to mention the data
and the SDI data set goes back to I
think like the early 1990s 1992 the
first quarter 1992 and runs through the
present so I'm going to look at six
different measures of bank size we're
going to look at total I'm going to look
at total assets which is basically just
everything that the bank owns and
categorizes as an asset I'm not going to
bother with what off-balance sheet
accounting means total loans so banks
make loans loans are a primary class of
assets but it's kind of a subset of the
total assets that a bank might have on
its books total liabilities these are
mostly going to be deposit tanking
deposit-taking institutions or
commercial banks there are aren't
investment banks in this data set so
liabilities are going to be deposits but
then kind of other
things I'm also going to look at just
total deposits as its own group and then
we're going to look at equity which
roughly speaking is just the difference
between assets total assets and total
liabilities liabilities plus equity
should roughly balance out the amount of
assets that you have and then kind of
just because it's in the data set I'm
going to look at total employees as a
measure of bank sighs so and if you're
looking at firms one way you kind of a
natural way to think about the size of a
firm or the size of a city is the number
of people in it but banks it's not not
clear to me that the number of employees
is a terribly good measure of the size
of a bank but you can kind of throw it
in there for completeness and tie it
into what other people have kind of
previously done so they're kind of two
things going on in this data set that I
want to adjust for so one is inflation
so all of the monetary values in the
data set are in nominal figures so
there's been inflation in the US to
varying degrees over the last 25 years
and I want to control for that so I want
to rescale my data so that i get rid of
inflation and then also the banking
sector itself has been kind of growing
and shrinking and so I want to make sure
that I normalized for kind of growth in
the banking sector so I'm trying to
compare apples with apples here and so
that's basically what I'm doing with up
about formula right so when you start
looking at the data the thing that jumps
out at you immediately is that there's
just been an amazing amount of
agglomeration and consolidation and
increasing concentration in the banking
sector in the US over the last 25 years
so here's just a simple plot of the
number of FDIC regulated banks in the US
so in 1992 there were over 14,000 banks
in the United States and now there are
less than half that number and this has
all been driven by mergers and
acquisitions so this is not like you
might think that banks may be a bank
goes bust
well it doesn't actually happen
particularly amongst commercial banks so
this is the FDIC will not because they
act as the government ensure of all bank
deposits they typically don't want to
allow a bank to go actually bust because
then they have to pay the bill they have
to you know bail out the the taxpayer or
the the deposit holders of that
particular bank they have to pay out to
make sure that that well that's the
deposit surance portion of FDIC they
don't like to do that so what they'll
typically do is if a bank is about to
fail they'll come in on a Friday
afternoon after the bank has closed on a
Friday afternoon and then work through
the weekend to engineer some kind of
forced merger or acquisition with some
other bank and then on Monday morning
the bank opens up with a new sign out
front that's roughly speaking what
happens and so all of this has been
mergers and acquisitions and so you can
think about how mergers and acquisitions
that's kind of naturally going to have
an impact on the distribution of sizes
and banks so another way that we can see
the consolidation is to look at the
market share of the various size
measures that I talked about of the
single largest bank so in 1992 the
largest bank in the US was was Citibank
and Citibank had roughly three and a
half to four percent of the entire
market for say percent these are
percentages of like total bank
commercial banking assets in the US or
loans liabilities deposits or equity so
these are shares of US banking sector
and so Citibank had about three and a
half four percent along those measures
you come forward to today and you see
more variation in the measure but the
largest bank today which is JP Morgan
Chase in the US has over 12 almost 13
percent of all commercial banking assets
are under its control
and and then for deposits it's slightly
less about eleven percent but that's
still eleven percent of all commercial
bank deposits are controlled by jpmorgan
chase so if I was the FDIC I would be
very concerned about JP Morgan Chase
going bust because that's probably going
to put a large strain on FDIC's
resources and their ability to kind of
actually ensure the deposits in that
bank and you see that there's a lot of
discontinuous kind of big jumps and
those have occurred for when large banks
merged with other large banks so I
mentioned that there is this mergers and
acquisitions trend that was causing this
kind of drop off in the number of banks
in the US you might think well maybe
it's these really baked banks going
around buying up community banks around
the u.s. and kind of consolidating them
into some kind of larger bank holding
conglomerate some kind that's not what's
happening I mean there is some of that
but that's not the whole story so that
in nineteen or about late nineteen
ninety-nine early 2000 that big jump was
when the largest bank in the u.s. bought
the third largest bank in the US and
became i think it was actually bank of
america bought i can't remember now what
the third largest bank was but they bank
america bought the third largest bank
and boom there was a huge jump in the
market share of the single largest bank
so there's no natural scale to mergers
and acquisitions and US banking's what
now things get even more extreme if you
look at the share of not just the
largest bank but the ten largest banks
in the US so again go back to the early
90s early 90s you had roughly fifteen
percent of the US banking sector was
effectively controlled by the ten
largest banks it comes to today over
fifty percent of the entire US banking
sectors assets liabilities equity
deposits all of these measures are
accounted for in the ten largest banks
in the US
now another way another way that you can
look at the amount of consolidation and
agglomeration and the banking sector is
to look at I've called these the
survival functions you might also
they're basically 1 minus the cumulative
distribution function or sometimes
called the upper cumulative distribution
function or the counter cumulative
distribution function however you want
to label it or think about it plotted on
long long scales so if what you can take
from this is you can see how much
skewness there is kind of in the data in
these distributions that if if there are
very thin tail distributions then you
would see this kind of drop off and in
this plot on a log-log scale it would
not be so kind of nicely linear at some
point and a couple of things that I want
you to take away from this one is that
there's good data collapse so this is
from the normalization that I mentioned
earlier so I converted the raw nominal
values and rescale them for to adjust
for inflation and growth in the banking
sector and distributions that would have
been kind of more spread out because of
those factors collapse down onto for the
most part kind of a single distribution
and so the rest of the talk i'm going to
be talking about fitting probability
models to the upper tail of of these
distributions so one of the things that
you can see is that so in red I've
plotted the distribution in 1992 and in
blue the distribution in two thousand at
the end of 2015 and you can see while
there's good data collapse for the bulk
of the distribution as you get into the
extreme upper tail you start to see some
of the natural variation in the data and
in particular if you look at basically
all of the measures with the exception
of number of employees you see that in
the extreme upper tail in 1992 between
1992 and 2015 you see this big kind of
shift upward in the probability mass in
the extreme upper tail and that's where
you can really see the big banks
starting to get bigger consistent with
the market share graphs
but I just previously showed you now
what's interesting about the number of
employees is that you kind of get
something slightly different going on in
1992 between 1992 and 2015 kind of i'll
call the medium to large ish banks and
of course these are banks that still
have billions or tens of billions of of
assets but those medium to large banks
have kind of shrunk in size and it's the
really large banks that have expanded in
terms of the number of employees okay so
how am I going to talk how am I going to
fit these probability models to the data
well so there's a there's a particular
paper that I'm going to follow I've
linked to it you can go and read all the
gory details of the particular
methodology and why their methodology is
so much better than what had what had
come before them I'll touch on a few
things so I'm going to be fitting the
power-law model that I mentioned earlier
to the data we're going to use the
technique called maximum likelihood for
the power-law model maximum likelihood
is really easy because you can actually
write down the likelihood function and
do a bit of mathematics and derive the
maximum likelihood estimator you don't
have to use basically non linear
nonlinear optimization to minimize the
find the parameter vector that minimize
the likelihood function this estimator
is sometimes called the hill estimator
which if if there are people from the
finance community in the room they might
be for more familiar with the hill
estimator because it's often used in
risk analysis and extreme value
statistics and financial applications
but it's basically the same so the two
things I'm going to talk about are the
parameter estimates and then because
maximum likelihood is by definition
going to fit the best power law model to
the data we're going to do some
likelihood ratio test so we're going to
throw in a few alternative hypotheses
some extra distributions to try to fit
we're going to fit those with maximum
likelihood then we're going to do some
testing the particular flavor of
likelihood ratio testing
this is kind of a plug for the wrong
likelihood ratio test which I had never
heard of and so I got on to this little
research project but I it's kind of I
like it because it's the way that you
conduct the test you start with the null
hypothesis that both of your
distributions that you're testing are
basically equally far from kind of the
true underlying distribution they're
kind of equally misspecified and so you
get a hint of whether or not you have
enough data to actually say anything
about the two distributions so and you
will natural in the first kind of stage
of doing this test you kind of naturally
getting an idea of okay to actually have
enough data to say anything sensible
regarding the two distributions I fit or
maybe I can maybe I should prefer one of
the other but it's just has this nice
feature all right so let's jump to the
results 0 parameter estimates so these
are the parameter estimates for the
scaling exponent alpha and the power-law
model that I'm using as my kind of null
hypothesis so the black dotted line is
too so that was what you would expect if
zips law was was a good model basically
of the upper tail of these banking
sector distributions so there are
there's two vertical scales left the
left hand side vertical scale is for
alpha the estimated exponent the right
hand side vertical scale is the fraction
of my entire data set that is in the
tail so part of what fitting this model
there are two parameters that you have
to fit there's the scaling exponent and
then you have to determine the threshold
where the scaling behavior kicks in and
so there's data that's in the tail which
is above the threshold there's data
that's not in the tail and so then what
I have on the right hand side is the
fraction of data in my sample that
actually is in the tail and the gray
bands are the ninety-five percent
confidence intervals that for the kind
of classic maximum likelihood confidence
intervals and the one well there are
several things that I want you to
take away from this one is that if you
look at kind of assets assets and total
assets and total liabilities you get
pretty constant and stable estimates of
the scaling exponent over time and this
might be because assets and liabilities
are of the measures that I've considered
are the two kind of most course so like
they're the big totals if you think of a
balance sheet as being assets
liabilities and equity so assets and
liabilities are the big are the big bulk
of the balance sheet and some of these
other measures or subsets subsets of
those the other is not with with some
exceptions particularly for employees
and equity for the bulk of most of these
measures and foremost quarters in most
years zips law is not in the confidence
band on these parameter estimates which
suggests that it's not it's not going to
be a good model of the of the upper tail
of the distribution the other kind of
interesting feature is that so power
logs have these nice proper have this
interesting interesting that's not
necessarily nice interesting property
that many of the moments of the
distribution are infinite they're
undefined and in particular if you have
a scaling exponent that's strictly less
than two then the mean of the power law
distribution is undefined so that based
on the estimates that I have it it's a
nonsensical statement to talk about the
average size of a large bank in the u.s.
so conditional on being in the tail of
the distribution of US banks there is no
well-defined mean for that distribution
so the expected value there's of what is
the expected value of assets for a large
bank in the US it's it's obviously
always defined in the sample of your
data but the distribution that you would
fit to it doesn't have the theoretical
population moment to match it and
which I thought was interesting the
other is that the last feature that I
want you to take away is that if you
look at employees and equity and
deposits particularly with employees and
equity there are clear negative trends
in these estimates which is really
telling you something about the amount
of that the concentration and there's a
lot going on in the concentration of
equity and the US banking sector and in
the very very large banks in the US and
again there in the number in terms of
the number of employees a lot that we
saw from the survival functions of the
medium two largest banks were all kind
of shrinking in size and the really big
banks were were expanding in size in
terms of number of employees ok so the
estimated scaling threshold and so this
was the the other parameter that you
have to estimate in the power law
distribution and this one you can't
actually estimate using maximum
likelihood so what I've done is
basically use kind of a simulation
approach where I basically construct a
set of of candidate values for this
threshold this threshold parameter and
then I kind of search through those
values and try to minimize the the
distance between the trying to minimize
the distance between the theoretical
power law that has that candidate value
of x men and the maximum likelihood
alpha that you would get from fitting
the data using that x-men and then the
actual empirical data itself so if that
is probably a bit unclear in a bit vague
but if you have questions about that you
can ask ask me at the end and I'll go
into in a bit more detail mmm right ok
so
just to summarize that again before we
move on so zips loll doesn't look like
it's going to be a very good model the
scaling exponent and the the standard
error is on the scaling exponent for
most quarters and most measures exclude
too so they're inconsistent with zips
law and in the clear negative trends and
deposits and equity and number of
employees I think equity is particularly
interesting because equity is one of the
measures that is used by regulators when
they want to look at how vulnerable a
bank is to all sorts of calamities runs
or collapses or or just being insolvent
and so they keep a close watch on equity
and so the fact that the equity in the
banking sector is becoming increasingly
concentrated and might mean that the
really largest banks are in good
position in terms of equity and so maybe
the regulator's don't need to worry
about them but that would be hard to say
without really digging into like the
nitty gritty balance sheet details of
the kind of equity that those large
banks are holding or it might mean that
there are a very large number of medium
to large-sized kind of more like
community banks in the u.s. that don't
have a lot of equity and that the
regulators might might need to take a
closer look at them right so just very
quickly through the likelihood ratio
test so I one of the alternatives that I
included was kind of a control so I
threw it a very thin tailed exponential
distribution and it had better be the
case that the power-law model
outperforms a simple exponential
distribution so what's going on in these
plots so there's again two vertical
scales on the left-hand side is the
likelihood ratio test statistic and on
the right-hand side of the p-values and
the p-values are the red curve and the
likelihood ratio stats or the likelihood
ratio statistic is the blue curve and so
large positive values of likelihood
ratios
statistik are consistent with the
power-law model having being preferred
in terms of likelihood ratio test to the
exponential and then what you would want
to see is a very small p-value to
indicate that the difference in
likelihoods as measured by that our
statistic is actually significant and
you get insanely large values for R and
insanely small p values which is what
what you would have expected based on
the survival plots I showed earlier you
can do the same with a weibull or a
stretched exponential so this is another
distribution that's quite commonly used
to do to model heavy-tailed data but
it's not it's heavier than an
exponential but not not as heavy as a
power-law distribution and again you see
and still in most cases and although
there are some exceptions in some
quarters for some science measures but
again large positive values of the
likelihood ratio statistic and small p
values so the power-law model
outperforms the weibull distribution
another one that I looked at was a
truncated power law so a truncated power
law is basically just a power law x an
exponential distribution and that fact
that that has is its power law ish over
like medium to large-sized banks and
then when you get into the really really
large banks the exponential waiting
that's multiplicative on the power law
distribution tends to pool the
probability mass down and so you should
see kind of a on a log-log plot you
would see a line that kind of curves in
the very very upper regions of the
distribution and if you remember think
back to the survival functions i showed
you one of the one of the features was
that in the early 1990s you did have a
kind of you know a linear behavior that
kind of died off and the very upper tail
but then as you came forward to 2015 you
were
having the opposite effect it was very
linear and then if anything it was
starting to curve up a bit and that's
consistent with what you're seeing here
that you have negative values of the our
statistic for most of the 90s for most
of the measures which is again
consistent with which indicates that the
truncated power law is preferred to act
the pure power law distribution but then
as you come forward to the 2000s for for
some of the measures you start to see
that that even though the power law the
truncated power law has a has a better
likelihood ratio or the likelihood ratio
is basically the same or zero so
indicating that they have the same kind
of likelihood the p-values are no longer
significant and since the the truncated
power law nests the power-law model as a
special case because it's a power lot x
an exponential you can set the
exponential parameter so that it doesn't
contribute anything and then you just
have a pure power low again the
truncated power law has an extra
parameter so a model with more
parameters should always do strictly
better the question is whether or not it
does significantly better and what you
see is it does significantly better in
the 90s but then as you come forward to
2002 the 2000 intends it doesn't do
significantly better than then the power
law right so in summary the likelihood
ratio so it's the power-law models come
clearly performing better than the kind
of boring thin tailed data and then a
slightly more heavy-tailed weibull or
stretched exponential distribution and
then it does outperform the the
truncated power law the power-law
exponential cut off and as we get closer
to like the 2000s and then 2000 intense
more to the present right so the just to
conclude and kind of sum everything up
so if you came into this if you happen
to come into this talk thinking that
I bet that the distribution of banks in
the u.s. follows zips law because it's
just like firms or just like cities or
just like word counts or just like
everything else that follow the Zips law
you're wrong it doesn't follow zips law
it has a scaling it does follow a power
law but that power law has a scaling
exponent that is smaller and therefore
the tail is heavier and therefore the
banking sector is much more concentrated
and skewed than you would expect under
Zipf's law and it does better than using
likelihood ratio testing than other kind
of plausible models of heavy tail data
so thank you very much for your time and
I'm sure we have time for questions
yeah can you generalize you finally into
European banks sorry okay so the
question was can you generalize you're
finding two European banks well i would
i would greatly hesitate to generalize
without any data but if you know of
where i could get some data on european
banks I would be happy to plug it into
the pipeline and turn the crank and see
what comes out the other side my
suspicion is that the banking sector and
the and the European Union as a whole
would be very skew and would look
something like this whether it would be
statistically different than zips law
and the way that the US banking sector
is I don't know in the UK so I've one of
the reasons I'm not done this analysis
for the UK we said the UK actually
doesn't have that many banks so maybe in
some sense the UK banking sector looks
like what the US banking sector is going
to look like in 25 years and only have
like seven banks that take deposit
Institute deposits from from households
and firms and things like that so it's
hard to talk about the distribution of
banks just for the UK because there
aren't that many but if you think about
the EU as a whole then you're talking
about something that is approaching
basically the u.s. i went to expect that
there are on the order of several
thousand banks at least in the UK i'm
sorry in the hall of the EU but i would
be very keen if anybody knows where i
could get the kind of balance sheet data
publicly available ideally balance sheet
data on EU banks
any more questions
maybe a bit more common so like for
certain parameters who said the mean
doesn't exist you could also say the
meanest infinite so that sounds very
different right if you say the average
back I don't know what the average
bandage band bank is infinitely rich
these sound very different yes so that
that's a good point and so
mathematically it is infinite I mean
that's the value so when you try to
compute the moment the moment blows up
to infinity so maybe that is the more
kind of accurate way to characterize it
so I appreciate the comment it's
interesting though that in even though
like in the statistics literature even
though mathematically the function is
blowing up to infinity that you usually
talk about it as does not exist rather
than saying blows up to infinity and so
in some sense for like an academic
journal maybe it's better to say like
does not exist but I do actually think
now that I wish I had actually used it
kind of blows up to infinity rather than
does not exist because I feel like for
an audience like this blowing up to
infinity seems like it much better a
better way to characterize it so thank
you any other questions no emo gracious
oh I think it's time for lunch
yeah in the documents you mentioned this
sort of leads to policy decisions and
stuff like that in terms of how
significant the concentration of banks
is for like how risky the banking sector
is in the last ten years of hunting
there's been a lot of deleveraging is
that more or less significant in terms
of the effect on risk than this
concentration right okay so I think if I
the question it was not so much a
question as a comment about the the
recent deleveraging of banks the last
ten years and how the basically the
leverage is playing closing post 08 kind
of thing right okay so that basically
the the leverage in the banking sector
that we saw prior to the financial
crisis was a bigger source of risk than
the overall kind of concentration okay
yeah so that very well that very well
may be may be the case it might mean
that what I would want to think about is
somehow adjusting the size the size of a
bank to somehow take into account as
leverage ratio so that it might not be
appropriate to think about just the olin
balance sheet assets but somehow the
assets scaled up by the leverage ratio
and then somehow take into account
off-balance sheet items to see to then
get a proper proper measure of the size
so yeah so that's a that's a good
comment that's definitely something I
could look into doing because certainly
in and lots of risk models the leverage
ratio is a key and and also in policy
making circles the leverage ratio is a
key thing that they look at that or that
they actually try to constrain and to
make sure that banks don't go above a
certain leverage ratio particularly for
commercial banks I think so thank you
any more questions
I guess in the beginning you mentioned
that one of the purpose one of the
things you do is simulating economical
systems and you attempted to simulate
maybe the sizes of banks with a
distribution here but with your new
findings doesn't that complicate much
more your maybe the continuity of the
current research because you know first
of all you just show that first it
doesn't follow the Zips law reckoned
maybe a more general simpler
distribution good right so I mean my so
one of the okay so the question was was
doesn't this somehow complicate my my
original motivation which was I want to
come up with a reasonable glee good
approximation of the distribution of
banks in the u.s. that I can then use as
kind of a sampling distribution for a
larger simulation model and to a certain
degree it does in one sense that some of
the measures aren't stable and they're
kind of drifting over time which
suggests that the modeling the banking
sector is going to have to capture
dynamics that would somehow match the
dynamics I'm seeing in the data so yes
and one sense it does but my that's very
ambitious modeling objective so just
taking the I looked at it as a win in
that I was going to use before I looked
at the data I had been thinking well
this just use zip slaw because it's a
power law and it's going to be a pretty
good approximation it would be close
enough and then when I actually looked
at the data I realized well actually
zips law isn't what's in the data and
the fact that the fact that the tail is
so heavy and the real data that the mean
blows up to infinity has actual
implications for kind of the sampling
and the initializing of the
largest simulation model so in that
sense I viewed it as a win and just kind
of lifted up the carpet and kicked under
the rug the fact that there are these
drifts that ideally one would want to
model but it's very very complicated to
do and I'm not currently capturing it
and my other work so thank you okay
thanks dude yeah